[Musique]
quand j'ai une idée de texte enfin je
fais j'essaie de trouver une musique
bien
vous en avez besoin de très vite vous
vous attendez que les mots est pris leur
forme qui dansent tout seul non j'ai
fait les deux
comme ça qu'on fait
avoir interrogé de parler de moi au
début je faisais comme ça mais depuis
quelques années je me suis aperçu comme
j'écris à peu près toujours les mêmes
mètres je suis aperçu que j'avais usé
toutes les musiques instinctive qui
venaient s'ajouter aux mots pour le
faire danser voilà maintenant je fais
plus les musiques parce que je
retrouverai les mêmes alors je finis les
paroles et quand j'ai fini les paroles
je
je passe en revue toutes les musiques
instinctive qui me viennent dessus et on
cherche à l'autre
est-ce que vous n'avez jamais la hantise
de ne plus pouvoir faire de la chanson
c'est pas très grave
en réalité ça n'a jamais été fréquent
vous savez les chansons c'était pas mon
ma spécialité j'étais disponible pour
tout comme je pense de son sur les
attentes un peu prétentieux qui se croit
du génie à 18 ans
je me croyais disponible pour tout je
faisais les chansons en même temps qu'un
tas d'autres choses j'écrivais n'importe
quoi les jeunes ont cette force c'est
qu'ils sont disponibles pour à peu près
tout
alors les chansons la chanson était mon
violon dans le précédent mes vacances
mes récréations
il s'est trouvé que les récréations
avaient plus d'importance que tout le
reste
un public lui a donné plus leur a donné
plus d'importance
mais je sais pas une lentille je pense
souvent que
je pourrai plus aller plus loin mais
c'est une erreur on peut quand même
toujours aller plus loin
moi pour la même raison que dans la vie
on se fiche justement dans la chanson
aussi on se fait on écrit des chansons
puis on s'imagine que on a à peu près
tout dit on a à peu près tout dit
dans un certain style dans un certain
genre mais finalement la porte est
ouverte à l'aventure
l'océan
est grand
[Musique]